[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقه جديده مع
الاعلام الاسرائيلي وما يجري داخل دوله
الاحتلال وصديقنا الدكتور احمد فؤاد انور
مساء الخير معال الدكتور اهلا سيد بيه
صديق العزيز الله يخليك كان عندنا اسبوع
حافل بالاحداث والملابسات هل استاذن نبدا
بملف
الاسرى يعني اللي هو الاكثر
سخونه احنا سمعنا عن محاوله اسرائيليه بعد
مرور اكثر من 60 يوم من بدء الحرب يعني او
المعارك من 7 اكتوبر عن محاوله اسرائيليه
لتحرير احد اسرها بالقوه العسكريه هل يمكن
ان توضح لنا ما كتبته الصحف الاسرائيليه
عن هذه المحاوله هو الجانب الاسرائيلي
اعترف ب ان هناك محاوله لتحرير احد
الرهائن بناء على معلومات استخباراتيه
وانها لم توفق حسب الروايه الاسرائيليه
وان القوات المهاجمه منيت بخسائر وفي خبر
منفصل قالوا ان في حد كان تم اختطافه من
منزله حط خط تحت منزله
ا بالصدفه هو هو نفس الاسم اللي قالته
حماس قبل ب 44 ساعه وعرضت الصور قبل وبعد
في الفيديو اللي كان بيشد فيه الجانب
بالاسرائيلي والمسؤولين الاسرائيليين
للافراج عنه وقال رقم بطاقته ورقم هويته ا
توفى يعني قتل وواضح ان في اثار دماء على
جثته فالناس استشف بان في ثغرات في
الروايه الاسرائيليه او في عدم رغبه في
الاعتراف بان هي المهاجم المحاوله الفاشله
دي هي هي الخاصه بالجندي ده اذا انت بتميل
الى روايه المقاومه الفلسطينيه انه
الروايه اللي احنا سمعناها من الجانب
الفلسطيني وانا كنتت بتاكد من الروايه
الاسرائيليه انه اسرائيل حصلت على معلومات
المعلومات ديت استغلتها في محاوله لتحرير
احد جنودها اظن اسمه ساعر حاجه صح وان هذا
الساعر لما حاولوا ان هم يعملوا عمليه
تمويه واظن استخدموا عربيه اسعاف صح ولكن
اكتشفوا ان المقاومه رصدتهم وتبادلوا
اطلاق النار بس الطريف جدا في هذه الروايه
حاجه غريبه جدا اي ان اسرائيل استخدمت
يعني عرفت وارسلت قوات خاصه
ونخب ومش بس لحقت بها خساير ماخدوش الجثه
ايوه ولا ان هم قتلوا الاسير او قتل
الاسير اثناء ما اكيد حماس مش هتقتله لان
حماس هو فالي بالاسد بالنسبه لها كنز
بالنسبه لها لكن قتل اثناء الاشتباك او
قتله الاسرائيليين بطريق الخطا اثناء
الاشتباك لكن زي ما انت بتقول كده الاخطر
انهم عجزوا عن اخذ الجثه معناها ان هم
هرب يعني بالضبط وفي حاجات متعلقات بهمم
عتاد عسكري تم تصويره الاسبوع اللي فات مع
دكتور احمد انا كنت سالته ليه اسرائيل
توقفت عن او خرقت الهدنه او يعني انهرت
الهدنه بمبادره منها هو الاستنتاج
الاستنتاج ده انه اسرائيل حصلت على حوالي
50 من اسرها صح وانه هو وفقا لتقديره ان
اسرائيل لما هتستجيب هؤلاء الاسرى
بالاضافه للصور اللي هي التقطتها العمليه
تسليم الاسر وحركه ال كتائب المقاومه وهي
بتسلم خرجت منين راحت فين
هتحاول تستغل هذه المعلومات ل للوصول الى
طرف خيط وبالتالي هتحاول هي تحرر باقي
الاسرى بالقوه الحقيقه كلامه طلع مظبوط
لانه بعد عده ا توقعنا كمان انها تفشل اه
ده صحيح ده في حلقه سابقه كمان ده صحيح
انه ده فعلا حصل كلام انا احييه يعني ل
انه فعلا بعد عده ايام ا اسرائيل حبت من
الواضح يعني ان هي تستنتج من المعلومات
اللي اخدتها من بعض الاسرى تبني عليها
وتحاول توصل لطرف خيط وفعلا وصلت لطرف خيط
لكن وجدت طرف الخيط حاط يعني في حائط مزدو
انا عايز اشير بس لو تسمح لي يا السيد ان
في الاطار ده بيدور على صور هم عايزين صور
تطمئن الراي العام والهجره العكسيه في
نزيف من الهجره العكسيه الى بدل ما
يستقبلوا هجره في اعترفوا ب 350 ال نزحوا
اه في ناس قدرت وتبعت ازاي بن جوريون ماشي
وازاي المنافذ ماشيه فقالوا لا مطار بن
جوريون مطار بن جوريون فقالوا ان
التقديرات
المحايده بتتكلم على مليون وشويه تخطينا
غادروا بلا رجعه ده مكتوب في اه لان طبعا
لان في ناس بتتكلم على ان ده اخر تحذير
لقوات الاحتياط اللي مش تيجي القوات
الاحتياطي اللي مش عايزه تستجيب ده اخر
احنا زودنا العقوبه في مشكله ودليل برض ان
احنا اشرنا قبل كده الى السريه اللي هربت
بدل ما يعاقبها عملوا معاها مفاوضات تعالى
من البيت وهنشوف خلاص هنلغي العقوبه هنعمل
عقوبه مخففه ده ما انسحب زي ما قلنا من
معركه ولا من القطاع ده انسحب من الجيش
كله وهرب لغايه ما وصل لبيته فانا عاييز
اوصل لان اسرائيل بتبحث عن لقطه انتصار
قبل لقطه الصار اللي انا مهتم بيه انت قلت
معلومه مهمه احنا عارفين انه في هجره من
اسرائيل الى خارجها لان الناس نزوع عكس
على اساس ان دي دوله مهاجرين فهي عاده
بتستقبل المهاجرين فاذا خرج المهاجرين من
اسرائيل الى بلدانهم الاصليه سميت بهجره
عكسيه ايوه انا كنت سامع تقديرات بضعه
مئات من الالاف وهو رقم كبير 350 رقم كبير
قوي 3 القول ده اللي بتقوله السلطات
الرسميه انت بتقول ان في مصادر تان بتقدر
هذا الرقم بثلاثه اضعاف واكثر من مليون
اسرائيلي خرجوا باحثين مصريين اثق فيهم
وفي قدراتهم واستخدموا المواقع المستخدمه
العلنيه للوصول الى الارقام التي اتحدث
عنها تخطت المليون برقم كبير مش بس بس
مليون ده هي اليهود كلهم حوالي 7 مليون
ولا 7 مليون وشويه في مليون منهم غدروا
يعني صعب بتقليه لا لا ليه لا اصل هو مش
بيقول انا مش راجع انما في ناس افصحت ان
هو مش راجع ان احنا طرحنا
مساله الهجره وهو رقم يعني يحتاج الى
توثيق طبعا يعني ولكن انت بتقول ده اجتهاد
ويحتاج الى توثيق اكثر يعني كان في ملف
النازحين اللي انت اشرت له قبل كده انه
يهود كانوا طبعا تحت القذف في الجبهه
الشماليه من حزب الله وطبعا مستوطنين او
يهود موجودين بالقرب من غلاف غزه في غزه
بالك هؤلاء اللي في الجنوب تم ازاحته لمدن
اخرى واللي في الشمال دخلوا الى العمق
فدول نازحين داخل الاراضي اسرائيل او
اراضي اسرائيل اللي بتسيطر عليها اسرائيل
السؤال بقى مصير هؤلاء ايه السؤال ده توجه
لنتنياهو في لجنه الخارجيه والامن داخل
الكنيست مردش سكت احنا هنرجع بيوتنا امتى
السؤال ده توجه لقائد المنطقه العسكريه
الشماليه قال له احنا هنرجع امتى لهم في
24 اه العام المقبل يعني العام المقبل 12
شهر اه يعني ممكن تحصل معوقات في النص
يقول والله ما قدرتش انما الوعد في 24 ف
حاجه تخوف حاجه اولا اللي تم تهجيرهم
قاعدين في ظروف ضاغطه لكن كمان بيقولوا
احنا مش عايزين نرجع لما نطمن انتوا شوفوا
لنا بقى حزام امني من لبنان شوفوا لنا
حاله حماس فهم بيطلعوا دول صور ان احنا
بنتقدم اولا انا بضحك كل ما اسمع التوغل
في غزه وع عمق غزه هي 6 كيلو 8 كيلو 14
كيلو في اقصى عمق يعني فحاجه فهو بيقول
ايه انا بضرب اهو النهار على مبنى اه طبعا
اللي مش متابعين يقول لك ايه ده ما تقصفه
زي ما بتقصف بقيه المباني هو بيضرب على
الحيطه هو بيقاتل العدو وهمي هو بياخد
الصور ان انا واخد وضع الهجوم مش متاكدين
من الحكايه دكتور مافيش رد من المبنى ما
انا متابع ان المبنى لازم يرد هو بيتباع
اطلاق النيران مع حد الحاجه الثانيه ان
طيران بيدك هل هو بيرتع عن دك بعض المباني
عشان فيها اطفال ما بيرتعش فهو تاكد ان في
هنا مسلحين بيرجع كيلو والطيران بيجي يضرب
انت تقصد لو هو واثق ان في مقاتلين يشت مش
يهجموا معاهم هوه في العراء واحد فوق في
شباك اه اه بيضرب عليه الراجل ده مش موجود
اصلا ده مبنى بشباك عادي الشباك عمره ما
هيمثل عليه خطر لو كان هيمس عليه خطر كان
رجع وبعت الطيران فهم بيبحثوا عن لقطه نصر
او تقدم او في امل يا جماعه ما تمشو يا
جماعه ما تنزحو الحل قريب طب ما دام
اتكلمنا على لقطه نصر هم سعوا للحصول على
لقطه نصر الاسبوع اللي فات تحديدا يعني
منذ اخر مره التقينا بانه هم القوا القبض
على مجموعه من سكان غزه وبعدين جردوه من
ملابسهم وخذوهم قدام الكاميرات بعدهم
بيسلم اسلحه وقالوا هؤلاء عدد من مقاتلي
حما
استسلموا صح ازاي الصحف الاسرائيليه غطت
هذه الواقعه او هذه الوقائع وهل
الاسرائيليين استقبلوا ده على انه علامه
نصر ام لا هو الاغلبيه انتقدت بشده وقالت
دي فضيحه لينا امام ال لطمه اعلاميه يعني
دي جون ذاتي احنا احرزنا جون هدف ذاتي في
نفسنا لان حاولنا الطريقه دي في 2014
ومسكنا برض ناس وطلع لهم عرايا و وما كانش
فيها صد ولا في الداخل ولا الخارج يصب في
مصلحتنا المشكله الاكبر ان في تحليل للصور
دي الصور دي نزلت في كل الصحف الاسرائيليه
في الصفحه الاولى انما اللي تحتها السيد
هو اللي غريب جدا انا ببص تحت التعليق
الاقي ايه رجال حماس استسلموا واحد واحد
ثاني يقوللك
غزي يستسلموا رجال من فلسطين ا في الصوره
ا يعني مشتبه فيهم مدنيين اه هو اللي
بيقول ان دول مدنيين الراجل المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاصيلي الاعلام الاجنبي طلع قال يا
جماعه دول من المنطقه الشماليه شمال قطاع
غزه واحنا مسكناهم من التجمعات اللي موجود
فيها دلوقتي
بيسموها يعني مناطق امنه في الشمال لانهم
في عمر التجنيد وبنحب معاهم لو حد ينتمي
موظف لح حماس بنكمل معانا سجن لو مش ما
ينتمي لحماس بنفرق عنه انا طبعا لاحظت ان
مافيش ولا خدش فيهم هو لو مقاوم لاما في
معركه سابقه احنا بقالنا الشهر الثالث
دخلنا فيه او حتى في موضوع الاستسلام او
القبض هتلاقي واحد خدش كده مافيش خدش انت
انت محلل يا معال الدكتور ولا ولا راجل
مخبرات ملاحظات مهمه صحيح فالناس دي الناس
دي اعمار اعمار التجنيد او انما دول
مقاومه لا اه وواحد فيهم طلع صحفي فعلا
وواحد تاني اكاديمي يعني الناس وجوه
معروفه اه فهو اضطر يتراجع يتراجع لورا
ويقول والله احنا حذرناهم وميوش الله هو
انت هتبقى 350,000 واحد اللي هم موجودين
في شمال غزه الرجال الرجال اللي في سن
التجنيد في شمال غزه 3500 ال راجل اه
تقريبا اه هتبقى كلهم مشتبه فيهم ما هو
انت دلوقتي قدامك ناس تشتبه فيهم على اساس
اساس ايه ان يكون معه سلاح ان هو مثلا جوه
نفق عندك معلومه لا انه في اشتباه ده ليه
اسس اه طبعا انما مش راجل في سن التجنيد
وقاعد في شمال غزه تعالى الله طب ما تستقر
انت مش مستقرين من دول ايه انتوا فرحانين
ليه يعني انت مش عارف مين دول والروايه
بتاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي مش معتمده فالجيش
الاسرائيلي مش معتمده بمعنى انه مش مصدقها
ان في كل واحد اه زي ما ارتس كده طلعت
ويدعو طلعت ارقام مصابين من المستشفيات
وقالت لا ده في ثلاث
اضعاف الرايه الرسميه طلعت بشق الانفس
حضرتك سالتني قبل كده بيعلنوا مصابين ولا
لا قلت لك لا فالسؤال ده طرحته برض هارت
سالت لو سمحت اسمح للرقيب يقول لنا عدد
المصابين يعو راحت المستشفيات لقت ان
العدد 5000 منهم 2000 معاقين ام معاقين
اعاق ان الجيش الاصلي اعتر بيهم كمعاق
العمر
اه الجانب الثاني ارت سالت لو سمحتوا
عايزين رد رسمي قالوا لهم مش مش هنديكم رد
رسمي قبل الطبع بحوالي ساعه قالوا لهم
1600 واحد ام فارتس نشرت وقالت ان احنا
رحنا المستشفى لقينا ان في فجوه بين
الروايه دي وروايه المستشفى ثلاث اضعاف
يعني اقترب من
روايه اه سوري دعر اه فهي دي المصداقيه
اللي بقت على المحكم عاز اسال حضرتك اسئله
سريعه لانه النقاط كثيره قوي هل لديك اي
معلومات او يعني اطلعت على اي مناقشات
داخل الاعلام الاسرائيلي عن تصورهم
لمستقبل الاسرى ما انا عندهم اسرى ا يعني
عدد وافر على الاقل 100 عسكري مثلا في
اشتباك كبير جدا اولا في خيمه للاسرى اسر
الاسرى وزوي الاسرى والمحتجزين طبعا
عاملين خيمه اعتصام في القدس ففي واحد راح
حرق الخيمه دي والاغرب ان هو راح اعترف
انت حرقت اه حرقت فهو بقى وصلنا لمرحله مش
التخوين طب ليه حرق الخامه لان انتم بتعطل
الجيش الاسرائيلي انت الجيش ماشي كويس هو
متخيل كده او ان هو هيبقى كويس لولا ان
انتم بتنزلوا الروح المعنويه ان ان انتم
عايزين مفاوضات ان انتم عايزين تطلعوا
قرايبكم انتم تبصوا على مصلحتكم الشخصيه
فهو طبعا يعني ده بعد البعد ان احنا ما
وصلناش للتخوين وصلنا ل الاشتباك الفعلي
جاي يحرق الخيمه لا حرقتها فعلا انا
اعترفت فده بعد في واحد ثاني بيتكلم من
اقارب الاسرى بيقول نصر ايه ما انا يهمني
قريب يرجع طبعا ما في ما فيش حاجه اسمها
نصر انا بالنسبه لي قريب يرجع واحد ثالث
طلع قال هيبقى في ثمن غالي عشان الناس دي
تطلع بس فرصهم في الحياه هتزيد ده انا
دلوقتي كل يوم بيعدي ممكن يموتوا بسبب
القذف العشوائي فهو الحوار والمساحه اللي
اتثبت لهم برضو مؤشر على ان لا ان في
العسكريين بالذات في حساسيه بالنسبه له
ليه لانه عنده معلومات هو في اول يوم
هيديك رقمه العسكري
واسمه بعد كده عنده امل ان انت تطلعه
كجانب اسرائيلي بعمليه عسكريه بالتفاوض
انت مش بس اهملتني ده انت بتقصف ني اه فمش
في رغبه في الاستسلام استسلام مقابل ايه
سيجاره خش الحمام بدري لا في رغبه في
الانتقام الناس دي عندها لا مبالاه بمصيري
لدرجه ان بيضربوني
وبيضربوا المحتجزين ان يستهين بحياتي
الحاجه الثانيه ان ف ممكن يتصل تتعاون مع
يتعاون حتى ممكن بعد ما يرجع و هيبقى في
شك لو رجع ان انت ولاك لمين بعد ما اهملنا
ك اه اه هو متخيل ان هرجع في ايام هرجع
ازاي صمد انا انا قوي وشجاع وبطل وهدو
اخهم في الاسئله يرجعوا بالاسئله اقول لهم
نفس الاجوبه مش عايز اجاوب فات اسبوع فات
اثنين دخلنا في الشهر الثالث المشكله في
ان الجانب الاصيلي بيقصف مشكله الاخطر
موضوع الانفاق انا في النفق وفي كلام على
ان هيتم اغراق وان في طرمبات جاهزه وان
مياه البحر هتخش والاف اللترات هتغرق
الانفاق انا عايز اقول طيب ما انت كده
بتضحي
بالسر رسمي القصف قول انا قصف عشوائي ومش
قصدي كان كنت فاكر ان هم مش هنا اه انما
انت بتغرق الانفاق وعارف ان انت المحتجزين
بتوعك جو ايق في الافا وفي منهم مسنين زي
نتنيا سن نتانيا هجيلك على حكايه نتنيا بس
فهو الفكره ان هو هيبقى قرار خطير جدا لكن
في المقابل انا تقدير الشخصي قد اكون مخطئ
يعني ان فيتنام قامت على المقاومه من خلال
الانفاق مش بس ادغال فهو في حاجه اسمها
كوتشي اللي هو شبكه الانفاق اللي قامت
عليها
المقاومه الفيتناميه وعملت نتائج كويسه
جدا فهو الفكره ايه ان في خبره تراكميه في
موضوع الانفاق
والفلسطينيين متقدمين فيها جدا جدا جدا
بما فيها موضوع الميه ان انا هيحدث عليا
ميه ما هو بتيجي من الامتار اه هم متقدمين
بتيجي مياه امتار بتيجي مياه امتار فانا
في الانفاق بعمل حساب ان ممكن تحصل ان
تتدفق مياه فهو السيناريو تقنيا يعني من
باب الحرب النفسيه لكن في نفس الوقت يقول
للاسرى وذويهم بان حياه اقاربنا بنصدر
عليهم برض اعدام ميداني انا شايف ان في
تحت ناس بتوعي وبح نفعهم ميه فانت بتعتبر
ده نوع من الاعدام الميداني ل جنودهم وا
هل في تقدير
لحجم الدعم العسكري الامريكي والغربي
الاسرائيل بعد حوالي 70 يوم ما هو رسمي
وصلنا للطيار ر قمتين في المساعدات
العسكريه الامريكيه رسمي اسرائيل قالت
الحلفاء بتاعنا هم اللي هيدفعوا عننا في
باب المندب ورسمي ان في قطعه بحريه كبيره
جدا في المح متوسط وصلت بما فيها حاملتي
طائرات فهو المشكله بس ان الولايات
المتحده بتقصف في سوريا وبتقف في العراق
وان الراي العام نفسه يعني بقى متعكر اذاء
سياساتها فبقى الحمل يزيد يعني انا اللي
انا يعني بس بقرا السطور كده ان هو
بالنسبه
لهم علامه النصر الكبيره قوي ان هم يلقوا
القبض على قيادي كبير وليكن السنوار مثلا
او محمد ضيف او او يعني واحد من القنات
الكبيره حباد لو كان السنوار ممكن يجدوا
ان دي كده اوكي احنا حقنا اللي احنا
عاوزينه وربما ينهو الحرب اه وده طبعا
سزاجه برض يعني سطحيه ده استغفال للراي
العام لاسرائيل لان طبعا ما هو متاله كل
القيادات حتى الجهاد كان فيه والمبحوث في
دبي و ما توقفت يعني المساله ما توقفش
المسائ يعني حتى لو وصلوا للسنوار مش
معناها ان الدنيا وقفت سلم بس يعني ممكن
يعتبروا دي ع م ا هم هم بيقولوا ان شاء
الله اصبروا هنجيب السنوار وخلاص ايامه
معدوده فده علامه النصر بالنسبه لهم انما
انا شايف طبعا ده افلاس انما قتل المدنيين
طبعا مش علامه نصر ان استمرار شقات من
المقاومه اللي تل ابيه بنفسها يدل ان ما
فيش نص سقوط مزيد من القتلى كل يوم من
جانب الاسرائيلي بياكد ان ما فيش نصر عندي
سؤال مهم لو ليه اجابه سريعه نتنياهو تحدث
علنا امس على انه لا يستبعد ان تندلع حرب
في الضفه
الغربيه بين اسرائيل طبعا ومش في
المواطنين ده بيتكلم عن شرطه وجنود السلطه
الفلسطينيه نفسها ولا انا مش دقيقه لا لا
هو من البدايه هو كان بيقول ما تدم بنادق
اه ما تديهم بنادق يعني يا جماعه مين اللي
بيتكلم نتنياهو واللون ومعسكر اليمين ساعه
اوسلو اللي هي غزه
اريحه ابتدى يتكلموا يا جماعه انتوا
هتجيبوا شرطه فلسطينيه طب هتسحب بايه
هدوها ببنادق هيضربوا علينا فلما دخل من
زمان القصه يعني اه فهو بيكمل على الخط
اللي هو عمل بيه التحريض اللي ادى لمخ
رابين في النهايه اه س 95 ايوه نوفمبر 95
فهو بيقول ايه بيقول
ا التصعيد في الضفه ممكن يوصل لحرب اه هو
الفكره ان نفس الخط اللي ماشي فيه بنفير و
سماتش وسوكت دول ده اخطر منهم برض بس
الاعلام ما بيغطيه قوي
ا هي هيجل الامور تشتعل في الضفه ما هي
مشتعله هو انت لاول مره بتستخدم الطائرات
في الضفه انت مش محتاج طائرات انت عندك
حاجز امني قدام كل بلده كبيره قدام كل
قريه في حاجز مؤقت في دوريات في
الهليكوبتر بتطير بتغطي انما ان انت تقصف
وان انت تطلع مسيرات تقصف وان انت تخش
جنين اه مخيم جنين و ومدينه جنين بتق حمها
كل اسبوع لا ده كده في مشكله كبيره
فالمشكله الكبيره دي ددل ان هو برض مستمر
في التصعيد هو يوم الخميس كان من المفترض
ان يكون في مسيره استفزازيه جوه القدس
نفسها الشرقيه جوه الحي الاسلامي لكن في
اخر لحظه كان بتطالب ب السيد بالغا
اه من المستوطنين في ظل الاجواء المشحونه
دي بتطلب بان موظفين الوقف اللي هم بيدير
الحرم ولا حول ليه ولا قوه معلا سلكي بس
معهوش سلاح وبيجي لاقي قصاده 1000 مجند مع
الناس المستوطنين داخلين فبيس مح له
يقوللك مش عايزينه برض مش عايزين موظفين
الوقف دول عايزين سياده كامله على الحرم
نفسه الامر ده تراجع عنه في اخر لحظه شرطه
الاحتلال سحبت الموافقه
انما نتانيا واضح ان هو عايز ست بس بس
احنا بنتكلم على الكلام وهو على تطور اخطر
من كده احنا بنتكلم على انفلات وسخونه ما
بين جيش الاحتلال وما بين المواطنين ده هو
بيتكلم انه الشرطه والسلطه نفسها ه تشتبك
مع الاسرائيليين هل هذا السيناريو وارد لا
لا هو طبعا انا بستب عده ان يعني مهما كان
الضغط في تنسيق امني وفي يعني السياسيين
بيخشوا من الجانب الفلسطيني يقولوا لا
اصبر شويه لا يعني احنا ممكن نستلم غزه
فايه اللي خلينا نخسر الضفه يعني هم عندهم
رؤيتهم انا مش معاها يعني بس الفكره ان
مروان بوتي نسب ليه بيان من جوه السجن
اللي هو امين عام
فتح المعتقل وقال انا ادعو ان الناس تحمل
السلاح وكل واحد يقدر يحمل السلاح يحمله
وتمردوا كده انما زوجته نفت واعتقد ان ده
الاقرب للصواب لان هو غالبا هيفرج عنه
قريبا ممكن اسالك سؤال لو كانت لي اجابه
حاضره يعني ايه اقصى الاسلحه اللي موجوده
لدى السلطه الفلسطينيه لو اردت ان تذهب
الى اقصى مد هل حل السلطه وبالتالي تترك
القطاع كله فوضى لاسرائيل ولا الذهاب
للامم المتحده ولا ايه هي طبعا لو لوحت
بحل سلطه هتلف النظر ان المشكله مش مع
حماس ان عموم الفلسطينيين هم اللي بيع
ان احنا اهو اللي اعترفنا باسرائيل واسقط
ن حل من البحر للنهر وتنازل عنه واكتفينا
ب 22% ياسنا تم وفكرهم بقى بعرفات وان هو
اسقطه الغصن الاخضر من يده ومقدم لوش الا
السم فده تبقى خطوه كبيره جدا وحماس هتملا
الفراغ مكان السلطه في الضفه هو بيقول
احنا بنقضي على حماس في في غزه لن يحدث
الفكره هتطور تتبلور والبديل بتاع هم
السلفين الجهاديين اللي هو جيش الاسلام
جيش الامه اللي هم داعشيين اللي ضربوا في
حماس وحماس ضربت فيهم وحطوهم في السجون ان
هم بالنسبه لاسرائيل ربما يكونوا اكثر
خطوره يعني الله اعل على الاقل سياسيا
يعني اه انما هيطلع حد تاني يقول لا حماس
دي كانت ما بتطبق شرع الله انا هطبق شرع
الله لا فعلا ما قالوها هربوا على سينا في
انفاق ايام الفوضه والصداح مداح اه بس
استاذنك ممكن نناقش تفصيلي بس نرجع للنقطه
الرئيسيه اذا الخيار الرئيسي هو انه انت
بتعتبر ان يعني خيار شمشون او الخيار هو
حل السلطه طبعا طبعا اه يا الولايات
المتحده اللي راعيته اصله ما بقاش في اصله
والنعش الاخير هو ميته فيلا ندفنها انا
اللي بيده شني انه السلطه على وضعها
الحالي بقطع النظر عن يعني دوافعها وانت
معاها ولا مش معاها المفروض ان نتنياهو
يكون حريص على ارداء السلطه لانه هو بيضغط
عليها هو بينتقد ه ده امبارح او اول
امبارح بيقول لا فرق بين السلطه وبين حماس
حماس تريد تدميرنا فورا والسلطه تريد ان
تدمرنا على مراحل ايوه هو بقول حما يعني
حماس بتقول انما السلطه عايزه وما بتقولش
هو دخل في النوايا وان بصوا المنهج بتاعهم
المنهج اهو بيحر ضد اسرائيل يعني المكله
مش في افعال اسرائيل مشكله في المنهج في
كانت مكالمه استمرت وفقا للاعلام
الاسرائيلي 50 دقيقه مع بوتين هو عمل
مكالمه امبارح وكان نتنياهو في اجتماع
الكابينت اللي هو مجلس الوزراء الامني
المصغر وطلع لهم خلاص انا طالع فطلع وبعد
كده 50 دقيقه عملت ايه يا نتنياهو قال هو
قال لي المدنيين راعوا المدنيين وايه تاني
قال لا ما انا قلت له بقى قلت له لا انت
علاقاتك مع ايران والتحالف مع ايران واحنا
ماقبلش ابدا ده خطر وقعد ال 50 دقيقه يعني
قعد يقول انا وجهت له يعني لوم وعتاب اه
لوم وعتاب وكده والمكالمه خلصت على كده
فطبعا ليفوف طلع افف اللي هو وزير وزير
خارجيه روسي يعني طلع وقال يعني احنا
الاغاثه مهمه جدا وان الموضوع واقف اطلاق
النار على الكذا وابتدا يقول تفاصيل بعد
كده نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي برده قال
احنا عندنا برض رؤيه ان لازم المحتجزين
يرجعوا بس قبل كده في الرياسه وفي لنا
طلبات يعني ان الموضوع ما طلعش من فراغ
فهو بينطق طبعا الكلمه اللي هو عايزها ويه
يعني هي وفقا لكلام نتنياهو انه تقريبا 49
دقيقه هو بيتكلم يعني هو بيتكلم ويخبط على
التب هو ايه الكاريكاتير اللي انت وريته
لي فيما يتعلق بهذه المكالمه وكان يعني يا
ريت تشرحه لنا هو في انا بالتق اشارات بان
اسرائيل غير راضيه عن جهات الجهات دي منها
تكرار مهاجمه بوتين فهو بيهاجموا ازاي
عامر كاريكاتير بان التليفون الاحمر اللي
هو الخط ساخن بوتن بيضع السماعه بعد
المكالمه ال 50 دقيقه وبعد كده الكادر
بيوسع فبتكون هو قاعد مع رئيس الايراني
ومع السنوار شخصيا ومع حسن نصر وحطين
خرايط ان هيخش من هنا وقوات هتخش من هنا
قعد معاهم في غرفه العمليات يقولهم ها
احنا كنا وقفنا فين اه فهو ده اللي هو ان
ده حلفهم ان ده واحد منهم سؤال الاخير يا
دكتور هو دلوقتي مع تعثر يعني مع طول امد
الحرب ومع تعثر جهود اسرائيل او املها في
ان هي تحرر اسرها بالقوه العسكريه اي بقت
في كلام كتير من على الاقل انا برصده يعني
مثلا بلينكن بيقول احنا بنحاول ان احنا
نعيد التفاوض مره ثانيه على هدى انسانيه
هم رافضين وقف دائم لكن نعمل هدى انسانيه
هدفه طبعا
اخراج الاسر وشايف انا في الاعلام
الاسرائيلي اللي انا بقراه باللغه
الانجليزيه انه بيتكلموا لا نعمل هدن
انسانيه
فهنا انت تتوقع ان يبقى في هدن قريبا
ويبتدى يتفاوضوا بقى على يعني على شيء
مقبول يعني اه انا اتوقع جدا لان في اولا
الاغاثه بدات تخش بوتيره اكبر وان الخسائر
الاسرائيليه وضغط الاسر ده بعد الطرفين يا
استا السيد منهكين اه بس كل واحد يقول لك
لا انا كمل للابد انا ما عنديش مشكله خالص
هو مجهد جدا زي الملاكمه كده اه طبعا فهو
الجانب الاسرائيلي دلوقتي بيقول ان احنا
احتمال نرجع للتفاوض انا بقول لحضرتك
التفاوض ما انتهاش لحظه اه الامور الخطيره
دي طوال الوقت ينسحبوا من قطر ينسحبوا من
كاس العالم هو في مفاوضات شغاله ليل ونهار
عشان يبقى فيه حاجه اسمها خط احمر او خط
رجعه او تنسيق ما او سقف ما حدش يتجاوزه
فهو دلوقتي المخرج ان يا جماعه في مصابين
ان يا جماعه في مرضى ان في يعني متقدمين
في السن عشان ز قمه حزب العمل تسكت وتهدى
شويه هو في اسباب كتيره ممكن يعني تبرر
وجود هدنه ما هم ما دام تعثر فكره بغض
النظر واقعه الجندي حتى لو اسرائيل شككت
فيها كلها ما هو ما لا تستطيع التشكيك فيه
انها عجزت حتى الان عن استرداد اسرعها
بالقوه يبقى يمكن استئناف الهدن الانسانيه
زي ما بيسموها وزي ما انت بتقول يعني في
الحاله دي اسرائيل لن تصر بقى على فكره
انا عاوزه ستات حماس بقول انا ما عنديش
اصلا ست
صحيح بس نستلف فهو الفكره ان دلوقتي ممكن
مخرج للحكايه دي بسبب الانهاك الذي طال
الطرفين ان يخشوا على المدنيين الرجال في
غير سن التجنيد او الاسهل المدنيين الرجال
المصابين طب وليه ما يدخلوش على ملف الاسر
العسكريين نفسهم يبتدوا يفضوا فعلا يعني
انا هقول لحضرتك هو المشكله بس المفاوضات
مركبه انا هعمل حاضنه شعبيه لمين لمرام
وتي ويطلع يبقى السلطه هي اللي طلعت الناس
لازم اعمل اخراج ان السلطه اللي طلعت
الناس
الفلسطينيين مش حماس الحاجه الثانيه ان في
اسرائيل عندها صداع كبير جدا هو اخراج
الناس بصور
وديه الصور ان باي باي باي باي مع
السلامه متشكرين جدا نشوفكم تاني في
الطوفان الجاي دي عامله صدمه في اسرائيل
عايزه تتجاوزها في اخراج القادم ازاي تضمن
ان ما يحصلش اللقطات الايجابيه دي ممكن هي
تتحكم في اللي جالها انت جيت قول بقى ان
اغتصبوني قول تفوا في وشي ما كانوش
بياكلوني كانوا بيعدوا عليا بال كذا انما
اللقطات دي بالنسبه لهم سببت ضرر كبير ان
المقاومه صامده ان المقاومه متحضره ان هم
مش جايين مثلا مرعوش خايفين من الطيران
خايفين من او ان هم جايين بهدوم ممز زقه
او لابسين لبس ملكي اذا فما يعرقل الملف
الاسرى استنتاجا يعني وارجو ان تصحح ني
واحد ان مازال عند اسرائيل امل في انها هي
تسترده بالقوه اثنين حتى لما فقر ابتدت
تفقد الامل هي قلانه انا لو جلست على
ماقره المفاوضات مع حماس هذا يعطي حماس
يعني قبله حياه ودعم كبير وده
يتعض اه اسطوانات اكسجين وده يتعارض مع
الهدف المعلن الق قضاء على حماس بالاضافه
بقى الى تفاصيل اخرى يعني ان هم يفضلوا
يعني انه المفاوضات دي تجري مع السلطه
الفلسطينيه بعد بس ما هو برض الكلام مش
مقبول ما هو انا لو قضت على حماس الاسرى
مع حماس مش مع السلطه الفلسطينيه يعني لا
يعقل ان مثلا هيقوموا بضرب حماس والاسر
هيفضلوا موجودين يعني محمود عباس قال
طلعوهم خلاص هيطلعو مش معقول مش يعني على
العموم هي اسئله كثيره معالي الدكتور
وتستحق ان احنا نطرحها في حلقه اخرى ان
شاء الله الله جزك جدا يسعدنا ربنا يخليك
شكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم في حلقه
مقبله مع الشان الاسرائيلي ان شاء الله
الاسبوع المقبل